all applicants for naturalization please
raise your right hands and repeat these
are a few of the United States 20
million naturalized citizens they make
up about half of the nation's immigrant
population and the Trump
administration's laser focus on curbing
immigration of all kinds has put these
Americans in the spotlight
the US Citizenship and Immigration
Services Agency is currently staffing up
a new office aimed at stripping
naturalization from people who they say
have cheated the process in short it's a
D naturalization task force while the D
naturalizations ramped up under the
Obama administration I don't think the
average immigrant felt any kind of fear
because most people believed they
weren't going to be a target of a
denaturalization application there are
also some changes coming to immigration
law that will alter decades of practice
it's much more enforcement oriented the
denaturalization statute should not be
used as a political tool to keep
everyone who becomes naturalized
basically on their knees with their
mouths shut and as long as they obey and
go along then they'll be okay
the country's immigrants could face
unexpected consequences including one
very high-profile naturalized citizen
you wouldn't have guessed hey fam i me
mayan and you should subscribe to this
channel right now because this sunday
we're taking a close look at how not all
citizen ships are created equal and the
one thing you should know if you're
facing denaturalization
[Music]
don't come to our country illegally come
like other people do come illegally
anti-immigration rhetoric has been a
part of Donald Trump's political
playbook even before he moved into the
White House but now the president's
agenda which often has focused on
illegal immigration is looking at those
who have already been naturalized and
those who seek to be and they yet to be
formally announced but expected proposal
the Trump administration wants to make
it more difficult for legal immigrants
aka those who did it the right way to
become citizens people like this I
wanted to become a citizen because
there's more opportunities here than
there is I'm excited to be an American
citizen so I can like explore take or
post plan which is the brainchild of
senior adviser Stephen Miller wouldn't
need congressional approval and it would
make it harder for legal immigrants to
gain citizenship if they or anyone in
their household had ever used some types
of public welfare programs we're talking
about things like food stamps Obama care
and even children's health insurance
this is an addition to that June 2018
announcement by US Citizenship and
Immigration Services where it said it
would double down on efforts to find
fraudulent naturalization and revoke it
Phyllis Smith has been an immigration
lawyer for twenty years and he's seen a
large increase in the number of
immigration applications coming across
his desk it's busy I'm getting questions
from naturalized citizens is this going
to affect me or are they going to try to
take away my citizenship there's more of
a confrontational nature to the
immigration applications Smith says
there are herbs and flus an immigration
enforcement but this current climate is
a distinct one if you have an office a
government office whose job it is to
take away people's citizenship then it's
only natural to expect that they're
going to be looking to take away
people's citizenship I don't think we
can ever be sure the government or any
government affair
Shoal is acting in good faith now before
you go skewering or praising trump and
his administration for their immigration
policy know this it's Obama's
administration that began operation
Janus a program that existed to ID
people who may have committed
immigration fraud so the same man that
said we don't simply welcome new
immigrants we don't simply welcome new
arrivals we are born of immigrants that
is who we are is the same person
responsible for an uptick and D
naturalization according to Alaska based
immigration lawyer Margaret stock the
Obama administration took a lot of
interest in them and they were doing a
lot more D naturalization than the prior
administrations had done under the trump
administration the process for applying
for immigration benefits has become more
technical more legalistic more
adversarial and people are more likely
to have to resort to court action in
order to get their immigration benefits
so it's not just felonies that can trap
you in the intricate maze that is the
nation's immigration system it has
become increasingly technical and
difficult to apply for citizenship the
forms used to be user-friendly the forms
used to be forms that the average person
could understand and that's not the case
today
it has questions that most lawyers don't
understand take a look at this
naturalization form it has 18 parts and
dozens of questions things like we're
your parents married before your 18th
birthday and the total number of
children you have including those who
are missing or deceased then there's
this one have you ever committed
assisted in committing or attempted to
commit a crime for which you are not
arrested that covers your whole entire
life so you could presumably be
denaturalized someday if you answered
that question no what they're trying to
do is give themselves an excuse for
taking away your citizenship decades
later critics worry a question like that
can be true for all of us for nearly
anything like speeding they say everyone
would have to answer yes to that
question which would affect their
chances of acquiring citizenship in a
very important Supreme Court decision
you may have missed last year
the government argued it has the right
to revoke citizenship even for a
seemingly inconsequential lie the Obama
administration took the denaturalization
case all the way to the High Court the
ruling came down in June 2017 which is
months after Obama left office
the case basically teetered on one of
the questions on that form we showed you
earlier did a woman knowingly give false
or misleading information while applying
for any immigration benefit here's the
tale the government tried to revoke the
citizenship of a Bosnian woman who lied
on her naturalization application
Diana Moslem Yaak said that one her
family fled sectarian violence in the
1990s her husband had stayed in Serbia
to avoid serving in the Bosnian Serb
army u.s. officials later learned that
wasn't true not only did the husband
join his family when they returned to
Bosnia but he also served in the army
that detail was enough for immigration
officials to seek to strip his wife
citizenship the Supreme Court was quite
stunned and startled that any
misrepresentation would lead to you
losing your citizenship the court said
they shouldn't be taking away people's
citizenship for some immaterial
falsehood that was on the application
the outcome of that case is very
important because it has helped set the
table but what's happening now with the
Trump administration stark says Trump's
team is using the Obama administration's
rationale to help push its agenda ahead
and the thing about denaturalization
proceedings is that unlike a criminal
case you're not entitled to a lawyer if
you're unable to afford one there's also
no statute of limitations all of these
rules and this tension surrounding D
naturalization of immigrants is so old
let me show you Mike hit him with a
tempo change when Theodore Roosevelt
signed the Naturalization Act of 1906
into law it created a mechanism for D
nationalizing citizens
it also federalized the naturalization
process for the very first time the act
was a revised version of an earlier law
that required immigrants to learn
English in order to become naturalized
citizens programming note unlike some
other nations the United States doesn't
actually have an official language the
law said you could lose your citizenship
if you lacked good moral character
that's a quote committed fraud or if you
were racially ineligible subsequent laws
expanded the offenses
and at one point women who married
non-citizens could lose their
citizenship status but according to
Smith there's another more overlooked
immigration law
he says his draconian and has become a
political tool against people who the
government didn't see as loyal we're
dealing with the the outcome of 1996 in
that law to this day and that was not
something that Donald Trump did that was
something that Bill Clinton did in terms
of limiting immigration law it's used
every single day thousands of times
President Bill Clinton signed the
anti-terrorism and effective death
penalty act in the aftermath of the
deadly Oklahoma City bombing it brought
as the grounds for deporting immigrants
it also became the first law to approve
fast-track deportations something that's
now widely used after 9/11 where the
government became more aggressive and
began looking at the D naturalization
process as a potential counterterrorism
tool we've slowly seen an expansion of
those cases
he says the result is the creation of
two different classes of citizenship
because the law protects natural-born
citizens in a way it doesn't for
naturalized citizens it seems a chilling
message to utilize citizens that they
are in fact not equal if they were to
engage in what is otherwise
constitutionally protected activities
such as freedom of speech and religion
if the government were to interpret
their activities as disloyal or
threatening then a government official
could attempt to take away their
citizenship both Smith and stocks say
they have to be very thorough when going
through clients histories so while the
Statue of Liberty may say give me your
tired your poor your huddled masses
yearning to breathe free what it doesn't
say is whether you'll be able to retain
your citizenship or that it'll be equal
if you do all of this emphasis could
bring scrutiny to someone like Melania
Trump whose immigration history
is a little murky if Melania Trump were
not the first lady she would be the kind
of immigrant who would be worried about
the current denaturalization proceeding
it appears she may not have been fully
truthful with the government on past
visa applications possibly on her green
card application and if she had some
misrepresentation in the past and it
wasn't disclosed to the government in
connection with her naturalization
application then the government could go
ahead now and take away her citizenship
both of the lawyers we spoke with faith
unlikely the government would pursue
denaturalization for something like
lying about your way or something
similarly small stocks says the
government doesn't even have the
resources to go after all the people at
seeking but she's still already seeing
an impact naturalization applications
from servicemembers have plummeted
they've dropped 65 percent after defense
secretary Jim mattis directed additional
background checks for non citizen troops
an October 2017
the one thing Smith says you should know
is that if the government is looking to
denaturalize you it's up to them to
prove their case they hold the burden of
proof not you
it should not be easy to take away
someone's citizenship because if it were
then the individual would always have to
be looking over their shoulder they
could never be comfortable or feel safe
and secure in a complete and full member
of our society so it should be a
difficult process hey fam thanks so much
for watching don't forget to Like share
and subscribe and go in the comments
section and let us know what you think
about this idea of two types of
citizenship is it the same as being
separate but equal' we would love to
hear from you and look forward to seeing
you next Sunday bye